so I want to back up a little bit and do
some kind of broad here which is that
you you've mentioned Sam a couple times
and little things that you disagree with
that you're saying are partly semantic
or and partly partly not semantic I
suppose I'm curious because our debate
in just in general in the country is so
we're so hostile to each other and
everyone's outraged and you know people
lying about each other all the time when
you take someone that you obviously
respect and like like salmon you have a
public disagreement with him or just not
that you're attacking him but they you
just disagree on this position how do
you go about doing it in a public way
that it doesn't veer into well I know
all the stuff that we see I know that's
not the way you operate in jails yeah
but I think it's an interesting place
because everyone's so used to attacking
everybody right if you even disagree
with someone without attack yes somehow
people don't even know what to make of
that
yes well Sam and I have never debated
any of these issues in public I'm not
sure he even knows that yeah that we
disagree on a few of these things I mean
we're in agreement was on so many issues
maybe a better analogy would be him and
Dan Dennett which a lot of a lot of
atheist are like oh no two of two of our
our big leaders are disagreeing on this
one thing it's like that's okay great I
mean I'm good are you kidding me
well but this is back to the tribalism
like this is our tribe and these are the
twelve things we believe in this group
here and wait a minute you know there's
a disagreement of course there's
disagreement yeah and that should be
perfectly okay but because the way our
culture set you know it's so tribal and
conflicting and and it's sort of a
battleground for ideas that it feels
like oh we got a we got to get everybody
on the same page so that you know that
the theists over there don't see that
the atheists are doing something over
here that is making us look bad
I'm on this is too much if any funny
though you'd think that the atheists who
are only bound by not believing in
something that's not provable you'd
think they'd be a little more flexible a
they but you'd think that the the group
think of it would be a little more
flexible intellectually to say there's
actually kind of cool like I actually I
like the fact right Sam has put
something forth that I don't quite I'm
not
right there on that you feel a little
different that like to me that's that's
what it's all about and yes of course
yet but instead of calling from that
yeah like I also disagree with Sam about
AI you know he thinks it's you know
possibly an existential threat I don't
okay that's okay but benefit if it was
just a bunch of scientists or
philosophers talking about things like
that survey I mentioned their
disagreement all over the place that's
perfectly normal but because we've
regrouped some of us into a collective
that goes against the you know the
Christian Right or the theists and we're
the atheist it seems like we have to
circle the wagons a little more that's
interesting so it's almost like we've
we've taken what should be scientists
and thinkers doing this sort of separate
we've throw them into pop culture right
and then they're trying to make
arguments in the same way they would
privately but now they're trying to do
it within the culture of Cronus and
right that's almost an unwinnable
yes edition i prom with labels atheist
it doesn't mean anything it's not a
worldview yeah
what are we we're humanists or secular
humanists or enlightenment humanists or
we believe in civil rights and civil
liberties and equal truck treatment
under the law we believe in reason and
science and rationality and logic you
know we need to define ourselves about
what we believe not just about what we
don't believe and when you do that then
atheism is like oh that's just this
little thing over here here's the stuff
in the big tent like when I got in the
movement the skeptic when he started
skeptic magazine in 92 and I started
looking into sort of visiting humanist
conferences and talking to the humanists
because there's sort of this division of
labor the atheist skeptics know the
skeptics and then atheists humanists
it's sort of two different cohorts and I
thought well can't they just be under
one tent well part of the problem was
Paul Kurtz originally separated them
when he started at skeptical Inquirer
magazine and free inquiry magazine is a
division of labor in part for
fundraising reasons and stuff but also
the humanists have a pretty strong left
progressive political agenda and and
Athey and and skeptics tend to kind of
be all over the place a little bit more
and and also that troubled me because
it's like well wait these are the 12
things we believe is humanists but I
don't believe four of these twelve so
what am I
I mean why don't we have to label forces
you into this box these are the things
in the box well but can I have half of
them in the box because I like the
Libertarians they have six of the twelve
points I like those yeah and by the way
I might swap a couple things yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah we should it would be
better if it was more fluid and the
labels weren't so so powerful yeah I
mean I spoke at the at the reason rally
in DC a couple months ago and I could
not believe the amount of in little
infighting amongst people and all of
this right I went up there and I spoke
about how we need to be the tolerant
ones and we need to not be platform well
that's alright and I'm surprised I was
good yeah all right so let's shift
topics a little bit let's go to free
speech because you are teaching now at
Chapman University they sent out a
letter basically saying and you can I'm
gonna paraphrase you can clean it up a
little bit but basically saying suck it
up we're gonna be down with free speech
and University of Chicago did this a
couple weeks ago and I do sense that
maybe we are finally seeing the tide
turn on some of what has been going on
at our academic institution I think so
yeah I hope you're right that's nice
okay good I think you're right well so
the University Chicago letter came out
and then I sent that to the president of
Chapman Jim Doty and I said hey we
should do something like this and
initially they were a little hesitant
like well we don't have a big issue here
at Chapman there's no big protest or
anything like that said yeah okay why
stir the pot and then he issues this
letter after hotline uh you know where
I'm into disinviting speakers and
trigger warnings and all that stuff is
like yes
good so you know my first day in class
there I said here's your trigger warning
there will be no trigger warnings you
know this is college yeah and looking at
a pushback did you get on that well
these are freshmen they're like you know
whatever okay they're still trying to
get oriented to life but but but I think
for the most part most people agree with
us that this has gone too far I think
the the vocal minority are they get a
lot of media attention you know you go
on a college campus you if you if you
watch the news you'd think oh my god
this place is the places are falling
apart you go there you don't see much of
this at all yeah it's really isolated
but it's still there and it's troubling
I just
to talk recently at Cal State Fullerton
because they had a big brouhaha last
year over Taco Tuesday yeah yeah you
know and the sorority got reprimanded
for cultural appropriation because kids
were wearing some bear yes you know this
is Southern California you know we have
a huge Hispanic population there's taco
trucks around I mean it's great so what
in any case America is a cultural
appropriation country that's all we do
so is there some piece of that that
we're missing as two white guys are we
not understanding something that we
should be sympathetic to here I think in
part it's a spectrum that yes what you
and I can't know what it's like to be an
african-american female in America for
example obviously so I've asked what
what is it that's really happening here
like a Chapman for example they have a
safe space for LGBTQIA members there a
Chapman okay so they had a meeting I
went this was last year what's it all
about
I'm just really curious and these are
the nicest people they're like we just
like to hang out and you know there is
some discrimination against the LGBTQIA
community here and you know so this is a
place and they were very nice about it
it's like okay you know we all kind of
have safe spaces your home I ride my
bike with my buddies every Tuesday
Thursday morning and we're in their
little group we talk about stuff I would
never say publicly you know and
everybody you know people have those
things so it's a little bit like that
okay that's okay fine
but then when I could kind of press a
little bit like well you said there's
been an upsurge in these kinds of
comments or incidences yeah yeah yeah
like how many I mean what are we talking
about one a week one a month one of you
yeah well you know we haven't really
collected data it just seems like
there's more emails coming to our little
group here like well is it how many were
there last year or the year before we
don't have any data
how many LGBTQI people are there in
Chapman University no idea we're not
allowed to ask okay so I mean is there
even a problem I don't know I don't know
I mean the people say well this happened
okay give me an example all right well a
gay couple was walking down the sidewalk
on the perimeter of Chapman University
and some guy in a pickup truck go by and
made a remark a nasty remark it's like
okay really because
that kind of happens you know there's so
there's ask all sorts of people for all
sorts of rises right there in others
there's [ __ ] in the world there
always will be
there's what can you what should you do
okay you can ignore it if you're feeling
frisky I told him you could say [ __ ] off
[ __ ] and then he says [ __ ] I and then
you know and then if that feels good do
it but if not I've done that I was in
Philadelphia once in the gay little
section there and some guys drove by and
called me and my friends screaming [ __ ]
yeah go [ __ ] yourself yeah that was it
no I yeah that was it I think yeah I
need to hunt them down and so is that
the problem that so you were asking for
empirical evidence yeah you wanted
something to quantifiably be able to say
oh there is a trend here yes right and
yeah as opposed to sort of young people
just sort of stepping into the real
world
right experiencing something and then
they're shielding themselves right
that's a problem because four years
later they're gonna get into a much
wider world and right right now again on
the spectrum thing like the Halloween
costumes issue at Yale last year okay so
obviously don't show up in blackface you
know if you're a white guy I mean you're
just a dick if you do that yeah just
don't do that yeah all right and then
they have a right to do it yes yeah
you're right over Rory to do it right
you're a dick right it's exactly like
when Ted Danson did this when he was
dating Whoopi Goldberg and he shows you
one of these awards her oh it was
complete backfire not funny and then and
everybody got the message okay you know
what that's just not cool
even though Whoopi was okay with yes
yeah yeah yeah and it said the scale
goes down from there like last year my
wife and I went to Bill Nyes house for
Halloween and she dressed up in a Native
American costume Oh Lord she looked
super hot and I loved it and you know
she we had no idea this was a culture it
was two years ago this is before the
cultural appropriation thing yeah
wow this is because it's like okay come
on now the blackface yes you know dress
up as a ghost no you know there's a
spectrum in between you know just use
good judgement so these are adults do
they really need a list like the
microaggression list that university of
california sent out to all their
students here's the things you can and
can't say one of which is you know
you're you speak English so well you
know to in a foreigner or something like
that well my wife gets this all the time
our English is perfect and you're from
Germany
you speak English so well you know
she says thank you yeah you know so but
but other things like wow you look so
pretty for a black woman you know that
this was an example that this
african-american woman gave on the panel
at this Cal State Fullerton thing I
spoke at it's like okay that is really
that's a pretty obnoxious thing it's an
obnoxious thing yeah but it's but is it
warranted of no I don't utilize my city
right right is all of this just a
function of our success actually as a
society I think so that's exactly it
it's that we've made so much moral
progress that our you know we've
ratcheted up these tiny little things
into something like it's like the
Vietnam War that used to protested in
the 60s now we're protesting Halloween
costumes right so this is a great take
away I mean that really is the if
someone wants to feel good about this
yeah conversation that the country is
having that's the take away right yes
yeah things have gotten so much better I
mean it's like we don't have to protest
interracial marriage laws that
prohibited it because we're done with
that gay marriage laws we're done with
that you know it's like so most of the
big stuff we've really chunked along
here nicely and now we're left with
these little tidbits and and so the
pendulum swings too far now language
does matter you know the n-word and so
forth yes that I get that but but not
all words are the same equivalent of
that and so when you start nitpicking
down here you're really taking away from
the importance of the the really things
that the things that really matter
yeah so when you see like black lives
matter we've seen it a couple
universities where they've either said
we're gonna have meetings without white
people or white people aren't welcome or
we or literally put white people in the
back right or a series of these types of
things or were they interrupted the
Pride Parade in Toronto right and said
unless you guys talking to the gays
which are thought of as another
oppressed group unless you guys sign our
list of demands we're not even going to
allow the parade to continue when you
see tactics like that I assume you think
they're the motivation is good right
like the the eye or do you well is it
just it's just gone completely awry at
that point well I think it's gone too
far for sure and it's not because
they're not inclusive in fact they're
kind of bigoted
and their exclusivity there they're
doing the very opposite of what their
claim they're doing and they're doing
the same thing the other guys they
clearly claim we're doing probably
really should just be called black lives
matter too because yes of course we
would all sign on with that as in also
yeah yes of course and you know that's a
it's a complicated issue you know every
one of those cases is different you know
police brutality on blacks and murders
and so on they're all different some of
them are clearly really bad and you know
these guys are should be tried for
murder other cases clearly you know the
guy was grabbing the cop's gun you can't
do that yeah and there you know
everything between yeah so the black
lives matter just sort of throws them
all into one this one big category
they're not this is part of our the
problem of our binary thinking we just
think it's all in this and all of that
that's sort of categorical we want to
put everything in a category forget it
just just call it exactly what it is you
know this particular thing here yeah so
how do you as a public person that
stakes out positions and writes about
all of this stuff and you know I don't
know of any topic that you would be
afraid is there something you would be
afraid to touch before I even finish
that sense no I don't think so yeah so
this one though because it's become
because when you talk about race it's
become so toxic do you ever find
yourself self censoring even for someone
as you said you have a group of friends
that you would say things to that you
may not say publicly yeah you find
yourself or yourself so bringing it
public way of course yeah at this talk
it callously Pollard Anna to preface my
comments and responses to the other
panelists by saying I don't know what
it's like to be an african-american or a
woman I don't I you know I understand
you know but you have to say that I yeah
and then then you know that's a way of
sort of acknowledging I understand that
you know your perspective is different
from mine and that a least allows you to
then say whatever it is you want to say
like if people are really saying things
like that to you like oh you're pretty
for a black woman or your hair feels
like a sponge and how unusual I find
even that I find hard to believe because
I'm looking out at a sea of Hispanics
and African Americans and Native
Americans this a huge campus with a very
diverse I mean people are really walking
around still say
stuff like that if they are you know
that's really bad but it's Amin right
and that's the thing it strikes me as
irrelevant really where and this is
saying where I think the left is fell
because they think that words mean
action you know you mean like right you
could go on the New York City subway and
be with every single type of person that
has ever existed
Ali an Eskimo there and a Neanderthal I
mean you could be with everybody these
people don't have to love each other
they don't have to be nice to each other
we have to act civilly towards each
other but you can have your own private
bigoted thoughts I don't like those
thoughts yes but is that the the thing
that's our strange social contract we're
trying to like untie that and make it so
that we all have to love each other but
really yeah we have to exist together
and you want as much coexistence of
course but we don't have to all know be
linked and you know what I love thy
neighbor I don't love my neighbors I
just just leave me alone
and yeah so well then the other problem
with the safe space is it sort of it
sort of sets up a situation where let's
talk about the things that happened to
us and build those up and then that sets
a mindset of now I'm gonna be looking
for those things and I think he made a
remark I'm just like like like like like
Woody Allen in one of his films yeah I
think he made a remark did he make he
said he said you didn't he say they you
know and it's like right if you wanna
fight if you want to find anti-semitism
everywhere and of course there again
there are some anti-semites still left
there are some [ __ ] still in racist
and yes you can find them if you really
look but again take the big perspective
it's just better than it used to be yeah
and then often you end up amplifying
their voices you know as I saw this guy
at the Trump rally one of the Trump
rallies screaming about Holocaust denial
which as you said you've debated people
on and I thought for a second I was like
that maybe I'll retweet this and show
what a fool this guy is and then and
then I decided not to because I was like
this guy's irrelevant why would I put
why would I use my voice to now put this
into the ether that this is even
something that we should be thinking
about all right about right I know Nanak
then people start looking for it and
then the labels I'm a victim of
oppression and bigotry I have a slide
and my thing about saying you really
want to create
safeSpace go to Somalia or Syria they
need safe spaces there and this one
woman's responses well my pain is you
know just as bad as anyone else's pain
you can't deny my pain okay so this you
know again this is part of the problem
you can't do this I'm a victim oh boy
here we go
you know people are really victims bad
things do happen to people it's not it's
how you respond to it that makes a
difference yeah how about we finish with
terrorism how does that terrorism okay I
didn't really have a segue there okay so
terrorism let's talk about it so the big
debate about terror I think basically
from every corner is is this doctrine
based or is this geopolitical based or
is it both and some people throw in a
couple other things but that that seems
to be the base yeah argument yeah yep
yep all right well almost all human
behaviors multi causal you know there's
multiple motives and I think with Isis
in particular al-qaeda but Isis for sure
the primary drivers religion you know
they they published an article and the
beak of you know this is why we hate you
this is why we fight you you know say
I'm did a podcast on it it's right there
one two three four five six you know the
first three are pure religion you know
you heretics who don't you know you
don't believe what we believe which
which would include by the way
Christians and Jews not just and random
people think that it duck that there's
some linguistic way that it doesn't
include the other modern religions
that's right actually not the game yeah
well that's what they say anyway yeah
now I don't know to what extent that
speaks for all Isis or whatever but
anyway and then you know then the the
second free so the first three were you
know denial of of our particular
religion denial of God so actually
theist and then you know attacks on the
Quran or things like that then the other
three were mostly geopolitical you know
you're over here in our lands you're
attacking our people collateral damage
drones and so on and they said this is
the this is the hierarchy this is the
primary one it's really religion and
geopolitics a second so I take them at
their word right so that that's my
policy is I take people at their word so
if they if someone you know says I'm
killing you because of something that it
says in this book whatever the book
might write right who would you know
John Kerry Oh Theo
well it's not you know it's not religion
or it doesn't reprobate well if the guy
that did it says it represents religion
then it doesn't mean it represents
everyone in the religion right but it
does represent that guy's feelings right
it only matters if you put it into
action yeah
now another a harder question answer is
to what extent do the leaders believe
that thing and the foot soldiers do they
also believe at the same way that the
Imams believe the religious doctrines
are these young guys are they in it for
the money the women the actioned the sex
and you know whatever they can get out
of it and maybe they also sort of kind
of believe the religion and it helps
drive it you know I don't know we can't
you know it's hard to get the data on
that you know Scott a Tran claims it's
it's more than just religion but I think
he's mostly talking about the foot
soldiers who they motivate to do this
both ideologically and it's good for
religion and we're gonna get revenge
against the Satan you know the evil
Americans but also you get some action
on the side a little honey an adventure
and a health care program and we're
gonna take care of your family if you
die again multi multi multiple
motivations but primarily really it
really is religion and I think we can't
deny that right and also the religion
part is the part that offers the
ultimate reward you know like the 72
virgins right all the other and all the
religions have their thing that you're
gonna get yeah but that is an incredible
it's almost incentive to have a horrible
life here yes you know you like the
worse your life is going to be the more
better it's gonna be water stuff there
you know it keeps making that gap wide
yeah so it incentivizes that only
religion could do that what else could
do that yes that's right that's why in a
set in a way it was safer when the
Soviets were the bad guys because as
atheist least they're not looking
forward to dying in the next life so
they don't want a nuclear war any more
than we do
right isn't that Sam's argument about
nuclear weapons that you know that the
Cold War led us to a you know a
standstill basically but you could have
an apocalyptic regime in Pakistan or
whatever where their actual goal is to
die as well
yes yes well so I mean
depends on who we're talking about Iran
is a state I think is less likely to use
nuclear weapons if they do develop them
because we can keep them in the club by
nations and keep checks and balances on
that harder for small terrorist cells if
they got a dirty bomb or something like
that hasn't happened yet I don't think
is an existential threat in the sense
that you know no no terrorist
organization has ever overthrown a state
and created a new state and and they
almost never get any of their political
goals as a strategy it doesn't really
work okay but what if they've got a bomb
and put it in New York City yes of
course that would be catastrophic not
civilization ending but because they're
not capable of creating a whole
stockpile of nuclear weapons they're
most they could get one but it's harder
than most people think I think and and I
think it's gotten better now under Putin
of keeping track of what happened to all
the fissile material and the and the
weapons after the breakup of the Soviet
Union I think it's safer now under Putin
I hate to say but really that's well a
strong man a strong man is we're good at
that yes certain that's right yeah is it
oh is it inevitable that we will destroy
ourselves with we can take this to the a
I think before we wrap up or or through
terrorism or whatever but is it
inevitable that we will just continue
creating things and more and more power
and have more and more people
centralized in where they're living as
you said before all but that all of
these factors will ultimately lead us to
a situation where yes maybe not every
single human on earth is gone but we
will lead ourselves to a situation where
vast majority just because the power
existed and there are bad actors really
that comedy right not impossible but but
not very likely I'm pretty optimistic
about the future I don't think I think
it's very a couple points about that I
really do think I mean most of the doom
day doomsday scenarios that have been
played out in fiction and in and think
tanks and so on over the last century
have not come true not even really close
and so I think there's reason for
optimism going forward none of this is
guaranteed yes of course you know we
could have a nuclear exchange there's
still about 7,000 nuclear weapons that's
enough probably to trigger something
like a nuclear winter
not to mention just raw deaths that
could do it I think it's very unlikely
that'll happen I mean courtesy fact it
hasn't happened since 1945 yeah that's
the trend lines are good you know of
course the counter is just you wait
right still happen but you know the
Marxist use that with the fall of
capitalism will collapse and every way
you know those are sort of secular
version or the environmentalists you
know all the all the people that live in
Idaho with their guns and gold wait for
the government to collapse you know it's
gonna happen under Obama okay you know
the government the government's really
they don't usually collapse it's very
rare and and stable governments like
ours very unlikely to collapse I just
don't see it I'm not even worried about
a I I think there's enough checks and
balances and the development will be
slow enough that we can you know keep
keep the keep the lid on pull the plug
yeah and and States can put regulations
on companies like Google and an apple
and so on that are developing AI just
like they do any other technology like
Tesla and the self-driving cars that's
going to happen but it's going to happen
in a with stepwise way that it will be
better for society and not worse I mean
it's not like the Tesla's gonna start
running over people on sidewalks to get
you to your destination it's just it's
not gonna happen right and interestingly
you're saying as someone that mostly
identifies I think is a libertarian
you're saying that some government
regulation related to that stuff will be
the stuff that keeps it in check so that
goes yeah we're yeah we all pick and
choose some of the things that make us
part of the team I've gotten a little
slightly less libertarian as I got older
just recognizing how much people cheat
to get away with to sort of push the
rules you got to have that you gotta
have really good well-defined rules and
enforced
jiggling sports I saw this in my own
sport of cycling you know these these
guys they just push the boundaries at
every chance they get and if they think
somebody else is taking the drug then
they got to take it because of the
slight advantage and it just escalates
into a you know an arms race and so you
got to have somebody put a lid on that I
saw Greg LeMond give an interview who
won the 200 fans three times and he said
you know where athletes are like
children we need strong parents going no
no no you're not gonna and I actually
now think what Wall Street traders are
sort of like young athletes in their 20
you know there whatever I can do I'm
gonna do it
okay well we're gonna you know we really
gotta have some boundaries here
I do think states and constitutions and
rules of law are necessary well I was on
steroids for this interview how does
that feel about that cognitive steroids
yes exactly
I thought you seemed really really
strong and sharp today more than usual
small balls for more of Michael and
skeptic magazine and and his books and
all that clicks up we're gonna put some
links in the YouTube description down
below or you can check out Michael
Shermer dot-com
thanks for watching we'll do it again
next week
you